[Music]
i was in new orleans about 12 years ago
with my friend rob and we were at a
restaurant with our at the time
girlfriends and
in walks the detroit pistons who at the
time were ruling the nba their best
player ben wallace was a monster he went
on to win the defensive player of the
year
on our way out ben wallace's wife
stopped me and she said this is ben
wallace and um he loves jeepers creepers
and i turned to ben who was right next
to her he was drinking soup and just
kind of staring at me and i said oh
thank you so much we're big fans of
yours and you know good luck this year
we're rooting for you and he didn't say
anything and i turned back to the his
wife and she said he doesn't like the
part where you go down the tunnel and
there's a part in jeepers groupers where
i go in but as there is in every horror
movie where you go and investigate the
noise that and then bad things happen
and i said oh well that's what you got
to do and you know it's a horror movie
and uh he finally dropped the spoon and
he goes
nah man you shouldn't have gone down
there and i got so nervous that i
started blaming it on other people i
said well you know the writers wrote
that and
the director told me to and he just
wouldn't accept that he was angry with
me
for the choice that my character made if
you ever had any chance of making the
nba that dream died no that night yeah i
stopped even trying life could be a
dream
life could be a dream
you're listening to life is short i'm
your host star of jeepers creepers
justin life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
we get it you're in jeebus creepers
that's a really good movie though all
kidding aside um yeah i think the first
half is good and you have such feathery
beautiful hair in it i it's a little
hard to watch just
my voice sounds i saw it recently my
voice is really different it's much
higher and kind of like
i feel like i was forcing things and i
don't want to get into that that still
is a movie that i often hear people
bring up with you to this day oh my god
20 years ago do you know
i mean this is going to be braggy but
barack obama's right-hand man
barack obama's veterinarian
um
no obama's right hand man this this guy
reggie love he was giving me a little
tour and he goes by the way man and he
goes i gotta tell you i love jeeper
scrapers and i was like oh thanks
and he's like and also you know who else
likes it and he kind of like gestured
over to the chair in the oval office and
i was like
obama
so he's like no the woman who cleans up
around here the guy you bought the chair
from the guy that reagan
upholstered the chair
that'd be cool too yeah yeah i'd take it
obviously you would never make the nba
yourself but you enjoy basketball i love
that and there was a time i thought i
would isn't that funny when you're a kid
like you think that's a possibility yeah
there's a time i thought i you did
really
uh
maybe i didn't have those ambitions
there were players that
you know ben wallace is this huge guy
obviously he's like joel embiid would
you say of his time yeah he was
humongous yeah and he was humongous he
was
like six foot eight six foot nine right
but but maybe the strongest guy in the
league in a league of extremely strong
people titans that story is appropriate
because our guest today not only has the
same chance of making the nba as you do
but
also i think enjoys professional
basketball as much as you do if not more
or i would say more he gets very excited
so our guest today is jesse eisenberg
basketball fan
right he's known as yeah i guess he's
also an actor and a playwright yeah he
does that too
but he's mostly a basketball fan
but he is one of the most unique
interesting people uh i've ever met um i
met him about eight years ago i think uh
after i'd seen a play that he wrote in
stardom i had been a fan of his for so
long uh and
he's just unlike anybody also justin and
i love this might sound very strange but
we love
watching
interviews on youtube
from
different different strange well
searching
specific actors interviews from
different shows but then there are
interviews like jesse eisenberg
interviews that are
so unlike those but equally fun to watch
because
he is so
fast and intelligent and
neurotic in a funny way that to see him
uh function in these short segments like
on the tonight show or something where
he has five minutes to
be it's so entertaining
to watch you know the host try to keep
up with him and to try to watch him fit
his story into a short amount of time
well i think that the interviews that
are fun to watch because they're kind of
going off the rails uh and they're and
they're not very good quote unquote are
because the people aren't as honest you
know again trying to sound a certain way
whereas jesse is unapologetically
sincere there's there's a real sincerity
like an earnestness to him that that uh
and because of his brain and his wit
it's just so and and his
anxiety it's really kind of fun to watch
so i was so curious to see how that
would translate to a longer form
interview like this a longer
conversation how that five-minute style
would change you know how his how his
style would change i was too and i was
also
a little nervous about it only because i
so respected him as an interview guest
and he has so much to say and such
interesting things to say that uh
i found myself just trying to keep up
and and
constantly aware that we weren't getting
to more interesting you know everything
we weren't getting to everything so for
anyone who's unfamiliar with him he
would not only was in school in the
whale which is a great movie if you
haven't seen it you should see it
uh he was nominated for an oscar and
every other award for playing mark
zuckerberg in the social network
and he's gone on to be in big movies he
played lex luthor and yeah superman
movie and he's he's such a wonderful
play right now too he talks about that
his mind works so quickly and is so
sharp and fertile that um
sometimes
his
mouth has a hard time containing all of
the thoughts you'll also hear a little
bit of his son his child's two-year-old
child who's in the studio as well that's
right who is
adorable adorable and he's like what
does this little kid look like he's so
cute um
curly hair and
really cute little face like a little
character and
afterwards after they left it hit me
that the kid looked just like
jessie's sister
hallie who people our age
may remember from those she was the
little girl in those pepsi commercials
adorable little hallie eisenberg and uh
so that adorable little uh son of
jesse's is going to start our interview
you're going to hear
he had a hard time with jesse going into
the separate room to do the interview so
to make uh just ease the transition yeah
we brought him in and uh we did like a
little mock interview or or a real
interview depending on how you look at
it and depending on how old you are you
might prefer that first interview
it was in some way easier because i was
intellectually
more connected
to the two-year-old than i was to jesse
um
so it was a little bit easier for me to
keep up um but that's how we're gonna
begin with jesse's son and then
eventually uh you're gonna hear from
jesse's son's dad jesse eisenberg please
enjoy
say and we're back
and you're back
yeah it's nice for you to be on my show
thanks say thanks for having me
well thanks hey what kind of treat are
you eating there
oh that looks good that's they're our
sponsor yeah say what happened to the
quip electric toothbrush
oh i have a good question for you hey
what's your favorite baseball team bull
ball
all right you're right he likes all of
them
thanks for being on my show say thank
you say when is this coming
coming
out
soon yeah and that's what what's the
demo
demo
mostly two and a half two to
three-year-olds say that's perfect for
me
you've been my best guess can you do me
a favor and say life is short
okay go in the fun place and daddy's
gonna be right here people get confused
i'm sure people get confused when they
meet you
as far as how you feel about yeah
somebody like zuckerberg yeah yeah yeah
people ask me all the time but i don't
have a thought about it oh really
i can't imagine what my thought would be
well i don't even have a page to worry
about my data being shared
isn't that amazing i yes you have
nothing no no i think most people feel
like oh [ __ ] my thing's being shared but
i don't have a page to worry about so
when i read about it curious i heard you
say once you investigated uh facebook
you you maybe took the first steps in
creating a facebook page oh yeah yeah
yeah exactly yeah exactly and you got
all these you were flooded with you know
your emails and people i would know and
there was people i did tangentially know
yeah yeah and that turned you off yeah
are you on publicly or i i got an
instagram for this yeah i'm sure but you
didn't have that prior to no i had a
private one which i really enjoyed doing
just with friends um
so you don't ever feel pressure
certainly not from
representation from your agents from
publicist uh to to do that no i mean if
anything maybe i would be pressured not
to because i say
things that are i mean probably like you
that you think are like funny in the
moment and then are deeply offensive to
a
many many countries or something or
people or yeah yeah and then i'm so
mortified and i have to apologize so i'm
sure i'd be either kicked off in a week
or have to apologize every other day
well that's how i feel about twitter i
never if if a thought pops into my head
that i think might be
witty or pithy or profound in some way i
immediately and
enough to share with of course publicly
all people i i never am convicted about
it enough to to let it
last you know so how do you resist the
temptation if you think something's
funny in the moment well i just
i don't go on it i just try to avoid you
also have other outlets yeah sure
especially now exactly right do
exactly was that uh an impetus to have
those outlets or did had you been
writing plays and uh oh if i didn't
write like stuff like when i discovered
mcsweeney's like 10 years ago um it made
me realize like oh this is probably why
most people have like twitter like
because you come up with a funny thing
and you want to share this is how i feel
but luckily i found like mix weenies and
stuff like that before i got a twitter
account but it's the same the feeling is
the same i have this funny idea and i
wanted urge yeah i wanted to let i want
to share it with somebody and um
yeah but if i didn't have that stuff and
if i wasn't a known person i'd be
worried about it i feel like i really
relate to you whenever i see you in
interviews i love watching your
interviews which is why it's such a
thrill to get to do this now with you
for me it's hard to receive compliments
it's hard to give compliments as you can
just see
uh i'm not comfortable with it how do
you internalize a compliment um through
self-hatred um
it filters through a long
process of
anger and yeah that's depression
i i figured it might which is why i
that i mean i'm not great at it in
general but that was a very halted
delivery
in terms of compliments and i i mean it
from the bottom of my heart i really
love watching your work and watching
your interviews but i
i think my hesitation is that i sort of
figured it might be received yeah what
about you it's similarly yeah yeah yeah
i remember the first thing i asked you
when i met you at that bar on hudson
street was are you jewish
right that's right yeah and i was so
flattered yeah yeah yeah yeah but you're
not i'm not and you're surprised by that
i still am yeah and in fact i think you
should do one of those ancestry tests i
think
i did we in fact ancestry.com thank you
for on the unsolicited mention of a
sponsor yeah yeah you know i did a
sketch once with um chad apatow in the
uh for funny or die and and
it was a bunch of actors all of whom
were jewish and it was craig robinson
saying to each of these actors
basically
accusing them of being anti i forget the
point but the the the the punch line for
all of us was that we all had to say
well i am jewish oh i see right and and
i don't think judd knew that i wasn't oh
right so it got to me and i and he said
what about you and craig said what about
you to man i said well i'm not jewish
yeah yeah and it kind of ruined the
whole i see
right right right um yeah yeah that's
why you always just say you are i should
yeah if you're in like a hollywood
meeting it's a good lesson yeah the kids
listening yeah
yeah exactly it doesn't apply throughout
all of history but at this moment yes
this is the the one little part of
history where it doesn't lie yeah yeah
yeah do you feel like your comedy um is
derived from like culturally jewish um
predecessors probably that's a good
question uh
probably it was heavily influenced i
think the marx but no not necessarily i
mean monty python and laurel and hardy
were okay not as much as like somebody
like woody allen i don't think so and
woody allen of course was groucho marx
was direct
that's true
you must have yeah yeah
i like that yeah and i liked kind of
more like you know comedy coming from
like and his comedy in particular comes
from like um kind of profound feelings
of depression and you know things that
are much more clothing yeah sure i think
groucho marx probably as well and i
heard he was like an angry person and
yet i heard harpo was a very sweet man
oh really
you know the siblings carry you know
they have to find their roles and their
attention from their parents there were
moments of i just saw the art of
self-defense and let you give yet
another uh incredibly layered
performance and and one that i feel like
only you could play because you are you
go from being so convincingly
um meek and beta to
having these moments of of
real
rage and aggression and you it's about
what karate does to this person um
yeah but it's about a lot more than that
i know it's a really interesting movie
it's a real oh thanks interesting did
you review it as a comedy because of
your background in comedy or did you did
i say it was a comedy did i reference it
no i'm just curious
when i first read it i thought this is
like sketch comedy i thought the
dialogue was like in fact the first
thing i asked the director when i met
him was did you ever write sketch comedy
because if you read it and i think you i
think you would you would like it if you
read it like it reads like sketch comedy
but it's performed and directed as
though it's very dark very straight
right exactly very grounded yeah um the
dialogue is so funny but because it's
directed in this way and performed in
this kind of deadpan way and because
it's even art directed in a way that
seems kind of comic or drab and not
colorful yes it has the feeling of like
a kind of um i don't know almost like uh
like a 90s like a hal hartley movie
almost yeah exactly and something that
feels kind of uh subversive and morose
rather than really poppy and funny well
but it does become not to give anything
away but
because i i think i was misled by the
marketing which was on the poster it
says a quirky offbeat comedy and yeah
and it is that uh for sure but
it does get a lot more um heavier much
heavier yeah it's absurdist i mean it's
absurdus but it's but the themes that
it's dealing with are
quite heavy yeah i mean the movie was
written like in 2015 before like
oh really the idea of like toxic
masculinity you know was discussed in
like a such a massive way and then while
we were filming the movie um like the
new york times and the new yorker broke
the harvey weinstein story this was like
i remember because it was on my birthday
but i don't think it was time for that
reason um but it was like october 5th
and 2017. nice little presents yeah
exactly and uh god it was amazing like
because you know everybody on the set
the cast and the crew were reading these
stories about people that we knew who
had these like you know horrifying
experiences that they never you know
talked about and just you know and and
also mortified that we were part of an
industry that hid this and knew this guy
who was this horrific person and you
know everybody kind of suspected was
horrific but not to this extent and then
we were doing this movie that we all
kind of thought was um you know kind of
a satire and masculinity and a satire on
in some ways like in cult behavior but
the movie then took on this new feeling
that it felt like uh i don't know i
guess it just felt like a much darker
satire on the dangers of masculinity in
the movie the movie doesn't touch on
like misogyny as much as it touches on
like violence even though there is a
character there are moments of that
though imogen puts his character
certainly deals with that that's right
yes she is a brown belt you can't ascend
to a black belt status and then is
assaulted too yeah that's right and she
talks about a previous assault yeah and
she um yeah there's even a line that
alessandra the sensei says something
like her being a woman will never allow
her to be a man and you know it's like
an absurdist line but of course yeah the
movie touches on misogyny but not to the
extent of course that we were reading
about in the news every day and um and
now since the movie's coming out now as
opposed to 2015 when it was written uh i
think people are filtering it through
the lens of um it being a kind of direct
you know commentary on toxic masculinity
the last few years and i'm sure you
probably experienced this a million
times where something that you do comes
out two years later and suddenly is
filtered in an entirely different way
sometimes for the better like in this
case and sometimes for the worse either
that means it's passe or it's no longer
appropriate to make those jokes has that
happened to you before i mean has that
happened with movies like even with any
and like when it came out i think and
yeah in retrospect it feels like there
was some elements of bad taste i guess
and especially because the family came
out and i guess i didn't realize this
while we were flying but the family came
out of the family of the guy who i was
playing who ended up was actually killed
in this thing and so when the movie came
out the family had kind of
you know i guess just
decided they wanted to say something
about it which of course is their their
right and i feel bad for them and so
yeah that was a case where like the time
that it took to come out kind of hurt
the movie but obviously i don't mean to
diminish the pain of the other people i
i try to be
as i think comedy really needs to
breathe and it has to be allowed
um
allowed to breathe which which
in the last few years has been difficult
with all of the
strictures being put on things and right
sure and i i've tried to be as sensitive
and empathetic as possible um
to that to to
but there are certain things that are
just
are dark and they're still funny to me
and right jokes that are made you know
10 years ago are then recontextualized
through today's lens and seem horribly
inappropriate oh god yeah i mean some of
my favorite movies you watch them now
and i love re-watching those movies and
yeah watch them now through that lens
and it's like
right it's a lot of good stuff you can't
do anymore right seinfeld if you watch
seinfeld right right of course you know
on the other hand i am aware that
progress means that we look at things in
the past and are you know that cringe
and that is also indicative of progress
and that's good stuff too because i
always think that there were people who
were watching i don't know seinfeld you
know seemed so benign but i imagine
there were people watching seinfeld and
cringing and they were thinking the kind
of thoughts we have now about you know
gender dynamics or socialism you know
that kind of you know or like gay panic
stuff like that that seems like you know
horrible now i imagine a lot of people
were feeling that watching stuff like
that in the 90s and so i think you know
now that we kind of are taking people
who are formerly alienated from
mainstream culture seriously i think
that's ultimately a good thing it's true
yeah and i suppose that's just a
byproduct of of yeah of progress and
other people having agency that didn't
previously have it and that's a good
thing yeah i mean as comedians if i can
throw myself there too like are people
who like comedy yeah you do feel like uh
you're being like policed more but i
always think well okay the trade-off is
that more people in the world feel
accepted and get to have a voice and i
always think okay rather live in that
society anyway that's true in the
society where i'm so funny
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and would
shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
hello hello again
we'll meet again
you you are so good at these at
interviews i love watching on them do
you enjoy doing them do you enjoy going
on conan and oh that i find incredibly
nerve-wracking probably yeah i imagine
maybe for the same reason you do which
is this i don't find it funny to say the
same thing again you know and so they do
these interviews beforehand where you
have to make your jokes about your cat
or whatever and then i feel incredibly
uncomfortable saying the same joke on
television yeah because and it's never
funny or at least it's not funny to me
you know to say the same thing it loses
the thing that made it funny the first
time that's right and i'm quick and i'm
depressed so it's a perfect mix for
these kind of shows you grew up with a
lot of anxieties
sure and and and maintain them yeah yeah
i decided to curated them yeah yeah yeah
exactly
why leave them back in childhood when i
could have them throughout my entire
life they keep you company yeah yeah
exactly um how how did with that anxiety
as a kid how do you then work up the
nerve to do plays uh i find them to be
well i don't like the moment before
plays i don't know how you feel about
this but then when i'm on stage i'm
usually okay and i usually write
characters for myself that are so uh you
saw that first play i did uh my
character such a crazed you know uh
that's right panicked individual that
all the
stress i have just is filtered into the
role isn't that great yes i could do
that but i i
i but the moment with that play that i
met you at was the first play that i
written and acted in and i spent every
day in an absolute panic before the
shows yeah now i'm a little bit you
seemed pretty much nervous afterwards
about how it was received oh yeah
afterwards i remember you saw it on a
thursday i remember everything i
remember everything because i remember i
remember because i remember each show
that i've done like actually that was
like seven eight yeah how long ago was
that that was probably 2011
um specifically october 18th no no not
like that but no no i do i do remember
when you came uh i remember when i knew
people that were there because i
remember specifically i was not a great
show i remember i remember you i
remember even telling you i think you
saw like a b-plus show is what i
remember thinking yeah i didn't think it
was like a great show but if you came
like the pre yeah and uh i loved it and
i think i was so like i'm okay on stage
usually i'm okay especially if i'm
playing a character that has some kind
of pent-up rage or something because i
can experience it but uh i'm not okay
during the days i don't know how are you
similar yeah and when you're at
williamstown do you have a similar
feeling or does it feel much more laid
back there because it's like it's easier
there yeah i suppose and certainly now
for me because i'm more comfortable i've
done
several years there and uh but it
doesn't have the same dynamic as a new
york audience coming to judge you that's
the other thing i've only done
off-broadway and um
uh so the plays like uh half the
audience are people like in the arts who
like you know coming from their own
plays and so you get a bit of that you
know the kind of judgment what do you
got kind of that yeah as opposed to like
um i am what i imagine to be a broadway
audience which is more tourism and happy
to see there see you and pay more money
and you know that's everyone you know
and and less judgey and kind of i had a
moment with the off-broadway with at the
vineyard um play that i just did where i
was so relieved once the the reviews had
come out and yeah i i think i didn't
read them but i i heard you get a sense
of course
obviously like people are people are a
little bit more upbeat of course or not
um and i think they it was it was good
it was and i of course my mother is
always like dropping little she knows i
don't want to hear about of course of
course but you can't help tell you yeah
yeah exactly
why don't you have some of these new
york times cookies i made you
specifically the third paragraph yeah
yeah frank rich uh
chocolate chip yeah yeah yeah my frank
which came out of retirement
this was a joke from 2008 yeah yeah yeah
exactly um yeah but but people said so i
was i expressed that i said oh god isn't
it nice that like now we can kind of
relax a little bit critics have and they
said um
they said yeah but now because it was
now people go in expecting something yes
or they want to hate it to diverge from
the thing that they read yeah exactly i
don't mean to describe all audience
members as cynical but i just mean like
i did i do have a sense uh yeah i do
have a sense like working off-broadway
especially in the stuff i do which is
like you're a non-profit theater you
know that the people and also i'm being
judged as probably you are as like you
know you're an actor who's known so like
there's a kind of you know this is like
you know it's an exclusive club theater
and so you know if you want to enter our
club you know you kind of have to that's
true you know there's a little bit of
heightened thing so uh yeah and in terms
of like the anxiety and acting i guess i
just feel a little bit more like um
i don't know i mean uh yeah i don't know
i have a lot i would be much more
hesitant to like uh
yeah i guess go to like a bar and
introduce myself to somebody than i
would to be and i think but i think a
lot of actors feel that way absolutely
yeah i think that's yeah you said
something about i think it was uh now
you see me
you were promoting that and you said
something about that role which was uh
you were attracted to it because it was
the guy who was the antithesis of that
he was very confident yes in fact in the
original script they sent me they said
oh we're going to be rewriting all the
characters i mean the guys who wrote the
original thing wrote a great script in
this wonderful plot line and everything
but they said oh we're going to be
rewriting all the characters so whatever
you want to play just tell us so i
certainly yeah so then there was a guy
who came in to do rewrites on it this
guy had solomon and
yeah you must know him and so like uh so
i said i just want to play like a kind
of arrogant guy and then you know say
this weird thing happens i don't know if
you've experienced this too this weird
thing happens where you're doing like a
scene as this confident or arrogant
person all day and then you start to
feel like you're doing a great job
just because you're making the faces of
somebody who's happy with themselves
yeah and it naturally infects your mind
just the way they say you know if you
smile it indicates you makes yourself
happier isn't that interesting to you
yeah and so i've had that did that
happen with with somebody like lex
luthor or uh
yeah yeah like house is like
machiavellian
yes except you know the guy who wrote it
this guy chris terry wrote this uh
backstory that my character was like
abused by his father and so actually
he's dealing with kind of all this you
know anxiety um whereas a movie like now
you see me there was no room for
backstory because there's about 18
characters and a bank heist to account
for whereas the batman movie is seven
hours long and you know it gives you you
know fewer characters so um so yeah so
it was less like it was less confident
more kind of like tormented rage
whatever but yeah no i do have that all
the time if i'm playing somebody who's
happy even in like a movie like the art
of self defense which is like the most
timid you know uh anxious person in the
world yeah there's little moments where
he experiences happiness and you kind of
go home the end of the day kind of
feeling happy and only the next day
you're like oh i bet that was because
the scene was happy oh that's
interesting yeah did you exp was that
part of the appeal as a kid when you got
because you got into it young right i
did like children's theater locally in
new jersey um so i didn't i don't think
had i didn't have any kind of like
udahagen freudian transference of a
character because i was doing like one
line and a musical i didn't it didn't
really apply to the process of the arts
you mentioned having a comfortable
upbringing a happy family was is that
was that it was was that the case we
were all okay
and who in terms of comedic influences i
don't want to dwell on the woody allen
thing but i often hear him in your
delivery there there are times
especially when you hit consonants at
the end of a word uh
i had a heart attack yeah yeah right
right i can't you know you can't fully
do it because then you sound like you're
in the 30s um and i did a movie with
woody allen that took place in the 30s
and i did i i felt like i was like i
allowed myself some extra emphasis on a
continent because it was
society society yeah it's like takes
place in the 30s and i thought okay this
is the opportunity for me to but i also
know how great must that have been yeah
yeah yeah indulge in your you know 1930s
depressionary jew my great but i also
noticed my grandfather talked when i
first met woody allen which sounds crazy
because i watched every one of his
movies before i met him but when i first
met him i had this revelation that he
sounds exactly like my grandfather and
after a momentary feeling of oh how
interesting i realized oh they come from
the exact same borough and the exact
same area and the exact same time period
so of course they sound like each other
oh they had a similar either your
grandfather had that cadence that yeah
exactly like this yeah and not with
jokes or anything but just with you know
marxist ideology and um i read an
interview with woody allen who said like
oh he casts martin landau in uh you know
he's not crimes yeah christmas demeters
and woody allen's not very sensitive
when he talks about actors so he doesn't
say like cause he's a genius actor such
a great you know he says i cast him
because he grew up on the next block and
he sounded like me and when i wrote the
character just wanted somebody who
sounded like me oh and so and so i
realized like and
did he ever explain why he cast you in
that in those terms yeah i mean
he used to tell me
you're not as good at the jokes as me
but you have more emotion so like i mean
which is exactly right which is exactly
the way i'd want it described like
that's amazing like you can't do all of
the
jokes but the character has emotion so
and i see he was he was basically saying
like i compromise you know the thing
which is fine
were there so he wasn't like there
weren't like heartbreaking notes that
you were getting
no the only thing that he said once that
we had like a kind of he there was a
like something he said uh you know this
it's not supposed to be raining in the
scene but it is raining here on the
location so just comment on it so i'm
supposed to be like on a date or
something so i said well god you know
just thank god it's not raining or
something you know some yeah the worst
improv line you could say
but just no no but i did it because he
just wanted me to acknowledge it right
off the bat and keep going so you can't
say anything that clever right and so um
i said something like well you know
lisa's not raining on a romantic
something whatever and he said cut cut
cut it is raining and i said you know i
know i know you said you wanted me to
comment yeah but you said at least it's
not raining i said yeah no i know
because you would wanted me to
acknowledge it he said
right so so so you you
you can't say it's not raining because
it's raining we could see it here on the
camera so you have to acknowledge that
so like okay so we did it again and i
kind of stressed the sarcasm a little
more like oh you know at least it's not
raining you know that kind of thing like
a worse kind of acting i said cut cut
cut it is raining we can see it's
raining i was like oh it's just and then
i was thinking oh maybe that's just kind
of like modern sarcasm that he doesn't
employ which is good because his
comedy's better than modern sarcasm
that's true but i think it's a
generational thing like that's true
that's what we would say all the time
it's not right it's a kind of a bad joke
that's true that's true and now that i
think about it because i know his movies
well he doesn't use that kind of sarcasm
what's the deal with that yeah nothing
like that oh thanks a lot there's none
nothing like that for somebody who
improvises a lot like um don't you
sometimes actually feel more comfortable
improvising a scene because the
expectations are different
much more when the scene is not well
written oh right you know right when
it's and i've been in situations where
they'll say that the powers that be will
come to the set and say hey
you know keep right because
we know that the script is not great so
go ahead and keep uh when it when it's
you you reminded me of this when you
were talking about uh ad living in a
sarcastic tone with woody allen i i i
was doing a robber i got to work with
robert redford which was incredible but
i was playing a part
i was playing the best friend role in a
movie that set in the 1860s
right after the civil war
and i just wasn't ca it just wasn't
equipped to do that the script was again
the script wasn't great and so they
encouraged me to ad lib and read write
oh in 1860s uh
yeah it was impossible and i found
myself doing things like like crazy
what's going on with lincoln here geez
[Laughter]
i mean it's one thing to proclaim the
emancipation but you have to do it so
loud yeah exactly civil war more like
uncivil yeah
yeah booth though the actor yeah yeah
yeah i should have shot him after i saw
his macbeth yeah exactly you mean the
actor hasn't done anything bad
[Laughter]
the actor who might have a brother but
maybe not because we don't know
they were like the baldwin brothers at
the time but i i uh i found myself
saying things like
um
employing very modern delivery like that
like what you were doing like wait so
you mean using language and sl like and
tone and slaying that was i i would say
things like james mcavoy played the lead
and i was his friend and i would say uh
well here we go again or you know very
like modern colloquialisms that like i
knew were incorrect and i would in my
head you know when you say something
like that in a scene you don't want to
get out of the scene but it's you're
aware of it and right was the dynamic
that was created in the script also like
a modern dynamic where like no no oh no
okay oh no it was all very period i mean
everything was like commit they were no
but i mean even having a friend who is
comic like something about that
true that doesn't exactly seem like
that's true and casting me i mean i was
right i had a big fake mustache it's
really really what is that it's called
the conspirator i hesitate to say i
don't want people watching but but uh i
it was i was
such a thrill to be in that company
right right but i knew that i was like i
don't know so i remember saying to him
afterwards i go to him for notes and uh
and it was everything was that okay oh
yeah justin that was great that was
after i had said something that i knew
was not was not even 1940 right right
right right right
maybe 92
that was rad yeah that was in an m night
shyamalan movie that also took place
around that time it was like 1890s or
something was that the village yes and i
actually uh he asked me to improvise a
line um and um i remember thinking it'd
be so cool i had like two lines of
movies i was like i was just you know
when you have like a really small
partner movie you're like let me just
try to subvert this somehow you know
what i mean to just make my presence
known and tell my friends that i was in
this movie and then i kind of did
something weird in it yeah and so there
was a line the line was something like
ah he was going to box my ears or
something i guess which means punch your
ear or something yeah why people do that
oh i see and so i thought it would be so
funny to just deliver it like woody like
a woody allen like a total woody allen
yeah i haven't seen the movie or if i do
it that way but i remember every take i
was like well he thought he was going to
box my ears and it was remembers like
crossing out a frame so i don't know if
it's even visible but i remember just
thinking like i don't have a really i
don't have a satisfying part in this
movie i don't get to really do anything
that i'm happy with so like i may as
well just try to subvert it from within
which is not i guess what people want
when they hire but yeah yeah but you
know sometimes you have to keep yourself
entertained too when did that stop when
when did you feel no longer feel the
need to do that to when you when was
that after social network right after
that movie um no also the funny thing is
actually i just remembered the movie the
twist the twist of the movie is that it
takes place now but that is spoiler
alert well yeah it's if you haven't seen
the you know yeah you've had 10 years to
watch it but like um so so actually
maybe within the context of the movie
that was like a red herring right you
know somebody snuck out and watched a
woody allen movie and then came back
into the film
you really gave it away yeah exactly
what do you call him m
knight um uh yeah knight is the name but
why not just go by it always confused me
m knight if you're making you know um
these
movies you know what and you have one
and it's a different name yeah i mean
it's amazing that's true yeah but like
my name by contrast like is like i don't
know i don't know jesse eisenberg what
does that imply some kind of movie about
a kid getting his bar mitzvah and then
he goes on a funny thing and then dates
a model and it's comic you know
i'm listening yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah wait a second writes itself yeah
yeah exactly what was your first the was
it holy uh
roger dodger was that the first oh yeah
wow yeah good well another movie i love
good research um and then and so of
course the squid and the way it was the
first time that i remember being really
strong like thinking this guy is going
to be around for a while thanks a lot
such an incredible performance what was
that experience like when working with
noah bomback were you familiar wait noah
had done oh what did he do he did some
other movies yeah um and uh no i wasn't
like familiar with him or anything but i
thought it was such a great script yeah
uh so funny but not intended to be acted
in a funny way yeah like the art of
self-defense but a completely different
tone but yeah um
but i love stuff like that if possible
and um it was like
in a lot of ways more mature than i was
in terms of its like creative ambitions
it was much more mature than i was so
when i was doing it i felt like oh man
this is so funny like
can we make sure it's really funny in
each moment because the script is so
funny and of course the answer be like
what no what are you talking about it's
like it should be like a real movie yeah
yeah it's funny like that's interesting
there is a lot of times i i don't know
if you've experienced this but like just
by
virtue of being like an actor you're
involved in things sometimes that are
better than something you would ever
conceive of yeah
yeah and it's strange as like a young
person i don't do those things
well
you have a sense that you're like that
you're not like up to the same level of
quality and you hope in some way it
infects you but i think in some ways it
has some bad things too because like i
think like people who are in the arts
like i need time to develop and go
through all the bad stuff that they
would need to exercise from themselves
so certainly you were i mean especially
for i was like 22 or something
but and so like um you know i think this
is like also one of the dangers of like
twitter and all this stuff is like the
jokes i wrote when i was 14 are in like
still like in on post-it notes at my
parents house and no one will ever see
them and like but if i had twitter i
mean i would be all over that because i
thought i was hysterical at 14. yeah and
so like um there's a sense of permanence
now that like you shouldn't be there for
a lot of of course not just because it's
a not because because things can be uh
offensive or something um but just
because they're bad and quality yeah and
you wouldn't want them out there um
that's why that director james gunn got
in trouble uh yeah well that's yeah well
that he said things that are kind of
like shockingly horrible thing yeah but
i mean but that's not like
like what i'm talking about is just like
just creating work yeah yeah and so one
of the weird things about being in good
movies and my geez i was like 18 to 19
when i did roger dodger one of the damn
dangers of that is like it doesn't like
it kind of like skews my sense of like
what i could be doing it can almost be
stifling you know what i mean
and um yeah part of the reason i started
writing plays and not really movies as
much is because like i wanted because i
had like a movie career that was like
doing like quality movies and i didn't
want to like i didn't want to like think
that i couldn't live up to the things
that i was known for acting in and so
when i started writing plays i was like
oh this is an area where people don't
know me and i could kind of work on it
myself and get better interesting and it
kind of so i'm not really judged on the
same scale there was much less pressure
because there hadn't been any there's no
frame of reference yeah exactly and it's
a different medium entirely so it allows
me to kind of yeah so i was pretty
conscious of that and um i think that
would be really liberating i would
imagine yeah yeah exactly i mean it's
yeah interesting that both you and
hallie pfeiffer who played your
girlfriend in the movie yes went on to
be well she grew up actually her so her
dad is like one of the great playwrights
jewels pfeiffer so
yes of course and and not to diminish
i've seen all her plays she's brilliant
and a genius and one of my favorite
writers so i don't mean to diminish that
or qualify no no no no but you came from
different but yeah and i think maybe she
feels similarly like oh if she's in
movies and everything yeah i didn't want
to kind of like i think wanted to have
some kind of separation there so now how
does that inform how you pick a script
to act and now oh i mean you know all
sorts of things as you know um i mean
like the art of self defense like truth
be told and you probably read a ton of
things like this too the kind of you
know typical nervous male protagonist
who finds you know his confidence
through
sport and
i mean dodgeball is such a brilliant
example of twisting that idea and really
skewering it in a really funny way and
article defense did the same thing it
takes these kind of tropes tropes that
you and i probably would not like the
kind of cliche bad version of the sports
movie kind of thing that totally
undermines and bastardizes that genre
that's true and it becomes like a kind
of in a way like an almost commentary on
the absurdity of the man finding his own
strength through sport because what the
movie shows is that actually the
strength that that some of these men
find there is really kind of disgusting
and brutal yeah when you unpack it at
the heart of it is something that's
actually quite uh savage and sadistic
yeah that's right i mean so like there
is a point like in the kind of rocky
genre where like the guy is really
building himself up and gaining
confidence and running up the stairs of
you know the philadelphia art museum
whatever it is in the rocky movie and
like in the equivalent in the art of
self-defense is like me going back to
work and punching my boss in the throat
right it takes these like sports movie
tropes and shows
yeah something i related to too i wish i
didn't but um it made me think about all
those moments in my life where i've been
confronted by
that kind of aggression that kind of
hostility and
and they touch on this in the movie but
um i i i then so regret not saying a
certain thing or doing a certain thing
you know you play monday morning
quarterback and you're like i now this
is this would have really shown them or
this is something you mean to fight back
either fight back or or
tell them off in some way like use your
words i i think i i'm much more adept at
using my word
[Music]
although maybe the bigger thing
happening is that you know to sell into
your sense of yourself because it's not
the best way to deal with the situation
exactly and
and something happened to me recently
where i had this
altercation with the guy i was doing
something very innocuous like um i was
on a country road and i picked up a
turtle to show
my my nephew who was in the car behind
me not driving he's too so i brought the
turtle over and showed my nephew and i
was walking back and this pickup truck
was driving by and slowed down and
stopped
and he just started grilling me what are
you doing here uh he kept calling me
flatlanders this was up in the
berkshires what is a flat lender i
didn't know but i used the context
because i imagine it's somebody who
didn't live in a mountainous okay okay
okay even though this is like a massive
it's not the albs yeah yeah you got like
gras like terrain and it terrain insult
yeah
typical mesa lover
he was a topographical bully yeah yeah
exactly exactly
go back to the planes
life could be a dream sweetheart
fincher he worked with the social
network this is a huge break for you
i've heard fincher does a million takes
uh yeah is that true
yeah he does he does which i i love i
mean the thing i usually don't like
about movies is when you have to you
know go to the next scene and you feel
like oh i didn't get an uh a good crack
yeah a movie like the art of self
defense you know because it shoots in
like 21 days the feeling usually at the
end of the day is oh i i i hope i hope i
kind of got it it's like my feeling
right now is like we have to now rush
and right and that's why i think we did
this at this time yeah to kind of give
you the sense that i can fully you can
embody what i feel um yeah and um but
also you know you you do so many plays
so you know by the you know 50th show of
the show you just finished you know you
still it still feels like oh i i i need
one more i need one more i get it yeah
so i never feel like you're done yeah
exactly yeah
yes and i like that feeling i mean i
like that feeling i've come to like
worry about it less like worrying about
oh did we get it or not less yeah um
more confident yeah how important was
with that was that movie specifically
social network in in terms of gaining
that confidence and and feeling a little
bit more secure in what you were doing
you were nominated for many awards you
won awards what was that process like i
don't know except to say like the arts
feels like an incredibly tenuous
unstable profession irrespective of
whatever successes you have in a given
moment
um
uh so i know i don't ever fee i've
i worry less but i wouldn't say it's
like out of more confidence i think it's
just i worry less as i get older and
closer to not having to worry anymore
because i'm dead
like okay the 20s are gone you know what
i mean i don't have to worry about being
25 anymore because i'm not do you worry
about the passing do you worry about him
death no not at all not at all really no
no no not at all i already feel like i
am so impatient you know with anything
that i feel like i can't believe
everything's taking so long to begin
with oh really yeah sure that's
interesting you know you you don't i i
say that it's interesting only because
whitney allen was such an influence on
you and so much of his he has such a
death fixation he was right about death
but he um
we know him as an older person so right
now you know i feel invincible
i know for sure i'll at least get to
there yeah yeah exactly i mean i have
plans for next week nowhere
without a care in the world i have plans
for 35 years from now exactly exactly
did you grow up with religion was was
that a part of your i realize only in
retrospect how important judaism is to
me culturally yeah you know i'm sure
like most people my age from the suburbs
in the tri-state area you know you uh
you know you had the every jewish person
i think who i'm friends with who has a
similar kind of you know has the same
revelation which is like wow i didn't
realize how impactful it was on my life
on my culture and my thought process
yeah um and
how have you realized that oh only
in so far as like when i read about
trends in jewish behavior or interests
or cultural things like it's totally in
line with my values my interests my you
know my experiences when you're
surprised that i wasn't joining i'm
still surprised i would get that i would
get your spit retested yeah but don't
you feel like that i mean i do
absolutely i i i was surprised when it
came back only like five percent sure
that but i mean don't you feel like you
probably get along with jewish guys more
absolutely yeah yeah yeah are your
parents like you
they are yeah
and and erotic and my mom i think more
so but i think a lot of that too was
specifically the influence of
comedians like woody allen and mel
brooks and yeah
is there anything you feel like you
differ from jews like oh i see that's
why i don't have that element
a lot of it is the i mean guilt compels
so much of what i do and i think my
guilt comes from catholic upbringing
right right right right
nothing that i can think of immediately
yeah i don't wear a yarmulke oh really
um oh sorry it's just here i'm sorry
that's a shadow yeah
uh i wear a lot of shadows on the
timeline yeah um were you a fan of the
superman the gene hackman superman
movies no i've never seen them really
like that yeah
i had never seen that i watched some of
the scenes before i shot the movie just
like well you did out of curiosity just
on youtube you know i you know
interesting i'm aware that it exists as
a full film as well but i just wanted to
see the uh lex luthor character really
you weren't afraid that that would kind
of influence what you were no it's so
different it is so different also tone
of the movie because that's different
yeah uh yeah i know that you do tons of
charity work what what are you
talking what are some of the causes that
are closest to you well uh i i maybe i
well i don't know if i initially met you
but through my wife um i probably met
you before you worked with my wife on
the 24-hour yeah yes so my wife works
and she works in 150 schools and the
five boroughs underserved schools
bringing arts education to um
uh to uh title one schools in in new
york um she also was the daughter of a
woman who started one of the most
important domestic violence shelters in
the country so we work with them and
what is it
oh that's called the middleweight house
we yeah raise the money raise money uh
two years ago to pay off their mortgage
is there a website that oh yeah
middlewarehouse.org um it's great and um
you know it's funny because like i did
so much um like publicity for this
campaign and like so people like even
people who like movies that i've been in
china were donating and we had to set up
a thing to get money from it was so
sweet and it's really amazing and so um
my wife is a a saint and a brilliant
woman and she so so i
whatever she
uh she's you know she works with a bunch
of organizations and nonprofits so um uh
and she's so smart about what she does
with these particular um organizations
so um all of my anything good that i do
is through you know her introduction to
it wow that's incredible and we want to
make sure we uh
make sure we'll put it on instagram and
all that sure uh
uh really quick uh why the pacers why
indiana pacers i know you're a big
basketball fan oh so yeah we kind of
live half the year in indiana and
they're the closest team oh yeah i mean
i also like the pacers and when i was
growing up when we were kids the
princess miller that was a great team
well it was tough for me because i was
at knicks i was closest i was going to
tri-state areas of course of course as
were you yes except i it rebelled
against all the kids who like the knicks
oh right and we even got a picture with
rick smith's uh last year my wife and i
who are yeah you know not very tall
people does he still have this little
mustache he sh he oh wow good memory
yeah yeah that little kind of not
anymore yeah that was linked mustang
that he was yeah i think
it's funny you know he's like a dutch
basketball player yes and there was a
kind of european quality to the mustache
like you know if like fascists used to
have that mustache yeah you're a charlie
chaplin i was thinking of that about
that mustache like chaplin must have
been
aware it must have been outraged that
hitler stole this his great comic
mustache yeah yeah what was it like
meeting he was such a huge man so nice
you know the weird thing about what we
do for a living is like it transcends
like it it's not like we only can talk
to like people who are in our profession
like we get to meet people that are like
you know like i know it's the weirdest
thing in the world and and i like and so
i think like when i meet basketball
players who to me are gods among men
yeah um not just because of their
stature but because of their physical
skill set and you know just the the the
the work ethic and all the stuff i'm
just fascinated by it and you know i
think they see themselves similar to me
like we're in the public eye and we have
similar kind of similar kind of concerns
and to me i just look at them as like
i know like you know you feel like a kid
again of course like zeus is talking to
me or something
and but i think they look at me as
similar because they watch me we you
know go both present at the teen choice
awards or whatever the things are where
they both have basketball players and
actors and so it's this amazing thing
that uh you told a story once about
interacting with basketball players when
you're watching a game and i would love
to see that interaction because you
strike me as such different types of
people i i forget who you is
specifically you were talking about but
uh oh like yelling during a game yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah and i i wrote a
thing called the marriage counselor
tries to heckle at a knicks game and
it's like a guy who's like really like
he's he's saying like you know go team
but also let's recognize the attributes
of the other team and you know the idea
and that's kind of who i am like i'll
kind of yell during a game but not in a
way that's offensive to either one
that's right my brother and i like to do
things like uh
even for the other team i always feel
bad for the other of course
they're remarkable athletes of course
they don't live in the city they're at a
hotel right yeah they just happen to be
wearing a different uniform right of
course yeah we'll say like you get them
next at least at least you're in the nba
you should right exactly you're one of
the 300 best players that's amazing you
physically what's a loss i mean there's
82 games and yeah i didn't even right at
the end of the piece was like i hope i
hope i hope you both i hope you win too
or that we can transcend the antiquated
notion of winning
you uh how do you
how do you have fun what do you do to
relax or do you relax it's not one of my
concerns i just i don't even like i
literally don't consider it i don't mean
that i'm like miserable but i never
think like it would be fun i don't think
i've ever started a sentence that way
really well just because like it wasn't
like a value in my life i was like oh
you know what it'll be interesting to
like do i mean yeah yeah my family never
thought like you know be really fun to
do today like and then really you
wouldn't take family trips and uh
no no but also like the pursuit of fun
seemed stupid like why would you go and
do that like that's what a waste of a
day but you're fulfilled in oh my god i
love so many things yeah yes but um but
no fun does the goal never know like i
really i'm writing like a book now for
audible i just cannot wait to get back
to my press all day and i'm like so
eager to get back so i have a really
funny idea for something and that's like
so much fun to me but it's like only fun
because i know it's going to accomplish
something yes in fact we talked about
this the first time i met you i said i
feel this intense pressure you said you
wrote this plan i said and we you said
why did you write this play or something
i i think we we discussed feeling this
intense pressure to like feel like i
accomplished something at the end of
every day yeah your recall is i'm so
jealous of it and i'm i'm abusing your
time these are going to be really quick
okay if you don't mind sure sure uh
lightning round uh okay what is your
most commonly used emoji when you text
i've never used one wow never no you've
never used i used one sarcastically my
wife last week
i said i said i was doing the laundry i
took a picture of myself and i said
hashtag twitter hashtag laundryday and
then hashtag some picture yeah wow never
used an emoji no no no no no no i sound
like a person who uses emoji no i can't
concise an answer into like 10 10
minutes on a picture it might be
beneficial to you right exactly
what i need if you could be a
professional athlete what sport would
you play basketball done next easy okay
yeah uh john stockton fan when you're
growing
yeah i guess he was the tiny white guy
yeah
yeah but yeah i guess
yeah but he wasn't on the suns he was a
rival yeah that's right you had more of
a marley build yeah yeah um if you could
have one snack food for the rest of your
life what would it be a snack food oh
maybe almonds almonds these are good
these are good wow you're mama's
favorite snack food as well really yeah
and kevin bacons oh really yes my two
idols
uh a favorite movie of all time if you
could i like crimes meters actually yeah
i love it i loved it yeah i could watch
that maybe one more time in my life i
loved it yeah why just one more oh cause
i've watched it so many times already
yeah yeah i already know what happens um
uh if you have to live somewhere else um
besides you say part-time indiana yeah
montreal love my channel oh yeah i've
never been want to go no now i really
want to go uh if you'd have dinner with
three people dead or alive whom you've
never met dead dead death they need to
be bad okay uh it'd be a quicker dude
you'd get to eat more yeah yeah of
course of course um
who's your favorite muppet
oh goodness
which muppet do you relate to the most
wait out of the sesame street and the
muppets so yeah
that's true uh i i consider whoever was
in the the wedding scene in
you know the muppets take manhattan at
the end oh god i would say any of the
muppets okay yeah i mean i guess i don't
know of cheese i have my uh kermit i
guess you know because he's yeah it kind
of yes self-aware okay yeah um if you
could have one superpower what what
would it be oh
geez i wish i could bike just a little
bit faster because i ride a bike
everywhere
yeah it's not a very ambitious yeah
i guess it's an electric bike so i guess
it's not a superpower as much as a
purchase it's really like an electric
bike you'd like to purchase to have more
purchasing power yeah
if you could be one age physically for
the rest of your life
uh 85 okay uh if you could be it would
could you just because your personality
would suit yeah it would finally i think
would make sense
why is he hunched over like that weighs
85.
oh in that case it looks great all your
ad libs would would work too right
exactly um if you could be reincarnated
my propensity for eating werther's
originals
makes sense if you could be reincarnated
as a non-human animal what would you be
oh goodness i guess one of the ones we
don't eat
right yeah yeah
but also one of the ones who doesn't eat
others so maybe poison arrow frogs
no no i don't want to hurt anybody else
so one of the uh i guess one of the
vegetarian dinosaurs oh okay yeah yeah
although of course i'd be immediately
extinct upon re-entry
good news and bad news you're one of the
great beasts
you've been dead for
one million years
uh you yeah you you you'd be uh they
sent you around to all these like shows
paraded around like a freak uh okay um
is that dogs or cats oh
cats are easier they're self-sufficient
yeah beetles stones rolling stones oh
really yeah yeah yeah wow yeah edge has
more edge more edge yeah
and and have you ever thought about
i imagine you don't think about legacy
or or how you want to be remembered uh
like an epitaph or something some sort
of
yeah do you ever think about things like
that no because i i genuinely the i
can't imagine the world existing in the
way it exists now without you
yeah no in like several decades i
imagine we're all going to be like in
bubbles somewhere on venus because the
earth is uninhabited that's true so you
don't even bother
letting it out no who wrote there goes
the neighborhood on his tombstone do you
remember that oh yes wait who was that
it was a comedian uh and i know i'm
gonna name a comedian who's still alive
by accident um there's yeah was bob hope
not here bob hope is no longer maybe
it's him maybe it's him uh
you know when you come across somebody
who you're surprised they're still alive
i hope that's me
i hope i live long enough so they were
like oh my god wow yeah maybe people say
that about me now but just in terms of
my career uh what there's a great one in
key west if you ever go there uh it just
says i told you i was sick oh really
yeah so really who's this it is not a
known person and it's not no okay then i
don't want to know about it
uh so i was going to ask you about your
value system but you just answered that
question all right sure
i i can't thank you enough for doing
this oh thank you this was such a you're
a natural questioner as well as an
answer that means a lot coming from yeah
that's great thank you so much because i
congratulations on it thank you i hope
we sold shoes from trees oh all birds 10
or 10 and a half that's how i'm saying
okay yeah i bet we can arrange that uh
this was a such a treat for me thank you
me too and and uh what's next you wanna
do you wanna talk about that's not
important you're just going home yeah
yeah yeah okay for dinner yeah okay yeah
definitely not lunch well i bet it's
gonna be great and yeah uh thanks thank
you thank you thanks thanks a lot
so
that just happened
i don't know if that's not good i don't
know if now was that a jesse eisenberg
impression or a woody allen i was just
gonna ask that you don't both have to
wonder if it's just
they're rather similar aren't they
they're so similar i wish you had talked
about woody allen
[Laughter]
uh yeah maybe we did too much but i just
couldn't get past it
woody allen was such a huge influence
on me and
obviously him oh my god listening to him
in general though
i don't know if this is gonna make sense
but
it makes me so anxious
but in a really good way oh yeah like i
i felt kind of anxious listening to most
of that interview but i really enjoyed
it too i i it's a strange combination i
know i and while i was doing it i had
this sense of intellectual stimulation
and
fear i guess maybe is too harsh a word
but the um
frustration of not being able to keep up
you know his mind works so fast he's so
fast but you know what i i don't know if
you realized that you were doing this
but
in the first i would say five minutes
you
instinctively i think we're just trying
to
match his speed so you were talking much
faster i was yeah and you were trying to
match him and i think
naturally i don't know which happened
for the chicken or the egg but at a
certain point
you both sort of
calm down slow down calm down into it
and relaxed into it and it became much
more manageable yeah point but at first
it was really kinetic and yeah and like
yeah
yeah he's just so he packs so many words
into such a short space and his mind is
so
fast and he has these you notice he does
these little like asides almost to
himself he has like little quick
conversations with himself he's like i
don't know why i said that that's it
yeah sort of silly but then anyway so so
what do you think about you know and
he's very curious about you too i put
myself in your shoes at one point i
thought i would be so intimidated
because when he was asking you questions
i thought i wouldn't say it fast enough
so i thought it would be really
intimidating to be asked questions by
him because he'd lose interest from him
speaking of his mind his memory is
incredible the fact that he remembered
meeting you on a thursday oh my god
seven years ago you know it's borderline
rain man i don't know if that's
all to say but it's he doesn't have it's
the good parts of rain man i mean rain
man yeah defense he's like rain man but
also sociable yeah yeah yeah it's the
best of both worlds i really enjoyed
whenever you were talking about things
outside of the industry because he has
such a unique perspective on things you
that the story you told about the turtle
and the guy who was so funny that the uh
what does he say he said he's like
you've got a terrain insult
the guy who called you a flatlander the
other day
so funny but he had a real kind outlook
on it when he said that you know in
terms of anyone doing something shitty
to you you shouldn't yell at anyone
because right who knows who knows what
they've been who knows what they're
going through you know and you should so
that's a really good argument for it
empathy was really i think he has a real
strong sense of empathy based on that
yeah outlook and and a very um
articulate way of expressing it you need
to employ more empathy and if the world
only did that be a better place he was
very surprised that you're not jewish
to the point where he couldn't let it go
yeah he kept bringing it up
and i i
i'm sure you would agree with this but i
would consider that a huge compliment
yeah i've always
sort of secretly wanted to be jewish
yeah
and i'm sort of surprised i'm not jewish
yeah based on my behavior i it's it's
just it's just the fact that that the
jewish tradition happens to be so rich
comedically i know you know and i think
the people that we like
yeah larry david and the marx brothers
they're carl reiner and mel brooks
there's just
they're so funny i know i know and you
know even now as you know
we love stereotyping on the show
but even now the people that i like the
the newer crop yeah the judd appetite
yeah it's i know i sort of feel like um
i i'd like to be a part of that group
comedically i feel very akin to them and
he yeah he couldn't let it go but he
still
i feel like he still suspects that i may
be
lying you know there is i think there is
an overlap
between
uh that type of jewish neurotic
guilty you know way of being and the
catholic totally because it's i guess
guilt is the common total is the
commonality between that and we grew up
with a lot of that a lot of guilt
um so i i think our family life was
pretty similar to
a jewish home oh
a lot of comedy a lot of interesting
comedies just being
able to um identify with it and relate
to it's like that split screen in annie
hall when they you know when you see his
family and then you see annie's family
and there and her family is like waspy
you know uh country club
type thing yeah colleen dewhurst is the
mom and she and that's when he says uh
when diane keaton says to woody allen
you're what grammy hall would call a
real jew
and woody owen goes
thank you
but it's true those two different and we
grew up we were much more like
his his family we were where they live
under the train tracks and there's this
constant sense of even though we were
from connecticut i mean we we were in
the same neighborhood as as more of that
waspi exact type of family i would say
but but you're right our family dynamics
was much closer to the to the woody
island dynamic and that's why i always
feel like i need to explain when i tell
people i'm from connecticut uh well i'm
from fairfield connecticut i always feel
the need to explain qualify yeah like
well we're not like we're not from like
the really rich yeah yeah
because that to me has always been
synonymous with
you know country club in fact i've
i never went to country clubs i don't
golf and it's something i'm not any
longer all that proud of but i think
there was a time when i was it was kind
of like a badge of honor when you were
talking about his ocd when he was
talking about his his anxiety yes and
you
explained that i also have that and you
were rubbing your hands together and you
said he's probably cringing listening to
this
i was cringing
what am i telling you about i saw you
listening to it oh yeah
because there's a visual component too
that makes it worse when i see people
rubbing their hands together i it's the
combination of the sound and the visual
that is
really has the most impact but just the
sound is i wonder where that came from i
don't know i must have had stops
i i'm guessing i had some sort of
traumatic experience i don't remember
while someone was rubbing their hands
together it's like your thing with dogs
you're not you like doctor you're not
crate you're not you don't like them
nearly as much as
i i do or a lot of people do that's fair
to say and i think as you got bit it's
as simple as that things that happened
in your childhood i'm doing something
right now that i that is a um a pet
peeve of mine when people do is i'm
playing with my bare foot because i'm
wearing these shoes and i'm comfortable
without shoes
and i'm it's gross shannon woodward has
a thing about that she's always posting
on instagram people putting their bare
feet up on planes and he was talking
about why he started writing plays and
am i wrong in saying that he didn't want
to write movies because
the expectations would have been too
high
people would have expected too much from
him i think so whereas there was
something safer about being in the in
the theater world because it was uh
entirely different yeah he wasn't known
in that world at all he had never done
that's what i thought i think so i think
it was just there were lower
expectations and less pressure which
that makes sense to me but that also
goes along with what he said about
worrying less the older he gets because
he's
closer to being dead you know so so
that's the same type of brain that
thinks
i have to
you know accomplish a lot and i put a
lot of pressure on myself
to do a certain thing and the older i
get the less pressure i feel because
there's just not as much time left so
it seems like he's
i mean he's he's got to be hyper anxious
about things and and he puts a certain i
would love to have explore you know you
mentioned like we talked about career
stuff and i i really wish we had more
time and and this is on me too i wish i
had gotten into some of his personal
just the way he sees the world outside
of
an acting career and i don't know how he
sleeps at night
his brain is so active that no it's hard
to imagine it winding down well that's
why i said what do you do for fun
i don't
pursue i forget how he answered that but
i said the pursuit of fun seems stupid
to me yeah that's something that
characters we've heard would say but but
i've never known anyone i know you asked
what he does to relax he said it's not
one of my concerns
[Music]
but i wonder where that came from and i
wish i could have explored that he
didn't actually want to
talk about family stuff and so i wanted
to be respectful of that uh but i am so
i'm deeply curious about
where he came from what his upbringing
was like and i think the fact that he
never used an emoji he's our first guest
to have not ever used an emoji our
grandmother is 102 and she uses emojis
yeah almost everyone uses emojis now oh
my god but that lightning round i was
going to say that that
i i could have listened to three hours
of him answering i know those types of
questions it was fascinating i wish we
had more time and i felt at a certain
point i realized the time we were
running short on time and i i then
started getting i picked up where i was
in the beginning which was incredibly
nervous
you asked if you could have three dinner
with three people dead or alive said
dead
and his superpower his superpower i wish
i could bike just a little bit faster
so that's a woody allen line i mean
totally that's
that seems almost ripped off i know i
know so interesting that he chose that
woody allen oh that's such a
nerve-wracking story when woody allen
didn't get that he was being sarcastic
about the rain about the rain it's a
great story how interesting unique i
know we say that a lot but
yeah he's we don't mean it we never mean
no this is the first time i've ever met
it
he's truly unique yeah and i could have
talked to him or not or there's a bunch
of people in that neighborhood his
grandfather grew up just like him that
neighborhood is just we're in the social
network
that's the thing i keep going back to
that people like that with minds like
that personalities like that they don't
go into acting it's just not
conducive to
a a career in entertainment he doesn't
have social media he talked about those
those anxieties that's why you know we
got into it a little bit but not as much
as i would have liked like how do you
how do you have anxieties like that and
we didn't get into his ocd's struggles
with ocd which
i really would have liked to um i wanted
to hear that
being someone with ocd i wanted to hear
more of that yeah next time next time
and i'm i'm yeah i'm kicking myself uh
four times because that's my ocd i have
to touch things four times we're doing
it now and he's blinking he's rapidly
blinking and scratching his head
aggressively
i wish you guys could see this right now
uh
yeah god oh have fun back on we'll have
him back on uh thanks for listening and
and we are getting your emails
uh please keep writing in to life is
short at wondery.com and uh thanks for
listening to life is short
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
thanks for listening to life is short if
you enjoyed the show
please give us a five-star review
obviously be honest
but i don't want to tell you what to do
but it would really help the show out
tell your friends to subscribe we're
available on apple podcast spotify
google podcast and every major listening
app as well as wondry.com life is short
is hosted by me justin long it's
produced by christian long and megan
monaco senior producers michelle miche
lans audio engineers marcelino
villalpando executive produced by
marshall louis and hernan lopez for
wondering
[Music]
wait what was the point uh
why do you like why is it why do you
root more why is it harder to root
for a basketball team in the playoffs
why do you become more attached to
football games
because they're when i'm watching a
football game there's so many teams in
the nfl
that i really don't like
whereas
so it's fun to watch the games and you
watch them as teams you watch them as
teams exactly so but i'm sort of rooting
for them to lose some time so even if if
i'm watching like the dolphins against
the bears
i don't really care that much who wins
that game
but i hate the dolphins so much that i'd
end up rooting for it would be fun to
root for the bears yeah so i'd end up
getting involved in the game
yeah whereas in basketball watching the
playoffs i'm finding it hard to focus on
the
and you're following because you like
different players so you're following
the players you see their faces for
years i i it's more of a player driven
league so i've i've become a fan
it's funny they never said admirer of so
many different players whereas the nfl
is like
tom brady and a couple other people yeah
it's basically about the team yeah
they'll never say
they rarely say like oh and tune blocks
for raper and and augustine they're not
exactly
and also there's only
not only five players playing at once
here right right that's big you see
their faces and their arms and their
legs yeah they're wearing like little
skimpy things whereas football players
are all covered up and there's time
there's so much time in between they're
like you see their resting face all the
time
like when they cut to football players
they're usually just like
yeah for like a second
they're just yeah they're just like
through the animals
they're like behind these things like
there's warriors who are wearing your
colors yeah
weird so you start you get passionate
about two yeah i really love the name
you start it's easier to identify like
to join the team to like be a part of
the game exactly i love the knits but i
don't
get that emotionally invested because
i don't like hate the other teams enough
right you know what i mean it's like i
prefer the knicks
but sometimes i do with basketball
but i like other teams
because the players but i will never
care about the knicks as much as also
you care more about foot you like
football uh i don't know i like watching
basketball
at least i know it's weird i prefer
football though
because you're more and why is that
especially
involved it must be and if you're games
i think this is just as impressive of
course the stakes are higher in football
each game means so much more right so
you don't want to invest as much that's
true it's much easier to be a football
fan that's true even these series time
even these series it's like
seven games
just do one it's true it's much of less
of a time that's what it comes down to
that's why football is
so easy and so popular it's true
if there were 10 games if there were 16
whatever each game matters 16 basketball
games holy [ __ ] that's true
each oh my god
oh you're recording this can i stop oh
yeah
you